so the rampant wobble is legendary and
as with a lot of legends they're not
always entirely true the RAM pack is now
on there so it takes a little bit longer
than now to to power up then you go in
there's the cursor so we could type in
our program again 10:00 print let's do a
hello this time took a little bit longer
to enter it into the memory go to 10 so
there's our program but as you can see
the machine itself kind of wobbles a
little bit as you're typing in code and
if that rampant one was too much we lose
the data but actually our one and we
haven't done anything clever here this
is just a standard old Ram pack but
actually if we wobble it move the
Machine around a little bit actually if
we now type run it's still working okay
so you know the RAM pack wobble the
classic one that everybody talks about
is the blue tech allegedly recommended
by Sir Clive himself and you would put a
piece of blue tape between the case and
the RAM pack and that would just stop
the moving I think in reality that
doesn't necessarily work that well how
strong is blue tech you know but we've
had some brilliant resolutions to this
so quite often we've probably had two or
three machines as xat ones and they
donated on a piece of white melamine
chip board and there's a bloomin great
big ugly metal aluminium bracket that
holds that so the piece of wood and then
there's another aluminium bracket that
holds the RIMPAC down as well they look
really ugly but actually when we laughed
about this we plugged the enemy tried it
actually if you still messed around with
and soo much it would still lose that
memory this one's particularly good
connections for whatever reason I don't
know that it's just good they actually
made it worse
because as the machine the connections
tarnished a little bit that got in the
way and the connections and that you
know caused more problems but the one
that I did which was a bit harsh I admit
is to take my machine out of the case
completely and chop the wires that hold
this connector in place and in solder it
directly to the back of
machine itself that was harsh but it
worked and I ended up and I really
regret this
taking a machine that I had at the tone
called a tangerine micro 1065 it's
actually a really quite a sought-after
machine now there weren't many of them
but just gracefully I took the keyboard
off it because I hadn't I particularly
used for that machine and I took all the
tracks off the back of the keyboard and
rewired the matrix so it matched the
Zajonc 81 and I had a proper zelich's 81
with improper keyboard and I've sold it
on RAM pack so it was absolutely yeah
I'm a completely reliable so what sort
of programs would you write on your oh
saw some random stuff I mean I had a go
at writing games I grand visions of
writing these amazing games I wrote
these kind of well I mentioned the game
called piece of Kroll that I've seen on
the NASSCOM some years before and I
wrote a version of that which I've
called crystal castle or caves I don't
know and I never did finish it
it was probably rubbish anyway but I did
you know adding up things you know kind
of bank accounts I was 11 or so so the
thing is what the most important thing
about this machine is the thoughts of
what you could do with it not
necessarily for a lot of us what we
actually did with it but that's just as
valid because then later on you know
you'd have that drive things go and do
it on machines that you know would have
more use to you later on a lot of the
time I was loading in things like lunar
landing and and and some of the games I
was bought the the maths pack the mind
this is the junior education pack but
Dad you know I wanted to meet to learn
so obviously bought me the mass spec and
I'd become a mathematician at some point
which still it's not happened so it's
not managed to get them to buy me the
games take I think these are about four
ninety ninety three ninety nine
I remember having I think two of these
and these hold a lot of affection for me
because they've just the look of them I
had two of these one was games one was
the mass spec and I had another game
which I think might have been an
analogue game maybe a Kong type copy or
smoke I remember now
but again I've had three original tapes
for it
there's a real branding thing there I go
well Sinclair I think was really really
cute on this side of things he was very
very much about the aesthetics and the
look and the presentation those products
and again although they take stick
you've got to look at them and look at
the you know the design the aesthetic of
these and realize actually there was a
lot of thought going to it having a
machine that was this small in
comparison with something like the MS
@atk
that was there you know there is a big
difference and there is a beauty to this
this came before but this was been the
sort of machine that people would
recognize as a computer I think for for
cried to come along and have a product
that looked like this it was space-age
at the time look at the manual the menu
itself has got that kind of space-age
representation on it and I think there a
lot is to be said for the designers of
these machines as much as they were
built to that price point they were done
in a way you know with a with a very
pretty professionally plastic molded
case so I think a lot has to be created
succinctly on that school and he had a
history of it as well miniaturization to
a fault in some cases you know he was
making miniature TVs and little radios
and this kind of stuff and the
calculators that was making sometimes he
was trying to get too much Institute to
smaller space and that caused heat
problems and whatever but you know to
have successes you've got our failures
and in my mind this is a huge huge
success and I think to a lot of people's
minds a really really important machine
the BBC put out to tender a project to
create a machine that they could use for
their television program so the
government were very much pushing the
idea of home computers and trying to get
everybody involved with them and
understand them what they were because
there's a bit resistance it's you know
computers they're gonna lose all their
jobs at this time you know this is
computers were the thing that were you
know kind of feared ins in some respects
so the government were pushing that kind
of thing and the BBC we're going to make
a programme about it they put out to
tender for this this project they
specification the BBC computer itself
was pretty much SPECT up by the BBC they
take a lot of credit for the way that
machine turned out and anybody could
come along and and produce that machine
or perform plans to do it
Sinclair did and acorn did apparently
Newbury computers Newbury new brain and
put forward something ultimately long
story short I called got that tender you
could argue they didn't necessarily have
the machine they were selling to the BBC
at that time and but they had plans and
they knew what they were gonna do to
make it and Sinclair just didn't get it
now the whys and wherefores of that I
don't know but bottom line is you lost
that and he was really angry about it
and you know field microman Connor puts
that into into perspective but some but
yeah it was just one of those things his
sort of specifications for the machine
that he thought should be used didn't
really match with what the BBC wanted
and you know you could argue that there
were there were reasons why
Sinclair probably should have been yeah
the cost is a big deal the BBC micro is
399 pound and for a lot of people they
use their BBC micros at school they
typed in lines of code really really
simple basic programs there's only kind
of the higher end students that were
that were getting in there and doing the
clever stuff so you could argue actually
the Sinclair probably did have and I
know actually was in schools anyway a
place within when schools and within
teaching because of the price point you
know a lot more students would have been
have it would've had access to it so
yeah I know schools had them anyway
you know they went out and bought it
seemed closed because of that price
programs on those tapes and load them in
from tape so that was feasible we tended
to spend ages just getting the volume
exactly right